now there are two ways to to speak slave
at least that you can do this question
I'm just going to show you one of them
the most likely that at this point in
the course you would use for this which
is to look at this food equality and to
say there's a fraction
gross I don't like dealing with
fractions here especially where the fact
it involves your variables of the
denominator I like that's a bit of a
disaster so how do I get rid of this
fraction and or what you think would be
if this were an equation certainly to
just multiply both sides by X times X
minus 2 in fact if this were equation
that is exactly what I would encourage
you to do its total distance this way to
go about this however it's thought and
it in equation it's an inequality why
does that change things why is that mean
now I don't suggest that you do this in
fact I say you can't anyone yeah so this
thing in this table right which I'm
about to multiply by to get rid of the
fraction because it's a variable because
it's a variable you don't know whether
it's positive or negative and so when
you multiply both sides by that what do
you do with the direction of the
inequality you don't we don't know right
you have to actually create cases do you
see why that's not at issue here
why is that not miss you here because
already because it's an equality right
there is no direction to this equal side
both sides are identical which is like
your boss by both sides by the same
thing everything stays fine not so over
here there is a way to overcome this
though instead of multiplying by X X is
2 I enjoy to multiply both sides by x
squared X minus 2 squared now I don't
select a vendor 2 right before I explain
what I'm doing x squared X Rose to sweat
the reason why this is more useful is
because how many square I've now got rid
of my problem what was like long before
is that what the denominator wants to
publish I'm about to solve right that's
what this does but squaring it rather
multiplying by just the denominator
means I do the sine right I now know
this thing is either zero or positive
which doesn't change the direction of
inequality do you agree with that so
therefore I know I can leave the
direction of the inequality where it was
but now I can start to cancel things out
and get rid of that fraction which was a
problem before right so let's have a
look the whole point of doing this is
that you've got these two guys going the
cancel out like that so what am I left
with
I've got 6x x - ooh hold on the
left-hand side it's at okay and then
you've got this on the right-hand side
okay so there was the first step that
was a bit of a tricky obstacle to get
over now what do I do in this case or in
most cases my easy that this point is to
expect right I usually explain what I
see something like this because then I
can collect like terms I can factorize
ba-ba-ba-ba is a terrible idea in this
case do not expect what is it about this
particular ratio that tells you we
shouldn't expect is going yelling
okay so the first problem that sort of
is glaring at me use this thing in here
is a quadratic right this is an x
squared term when you multiply through
you're going to add X to the power X is
to the power 4 and you're like I don't I
don't want to go there if I could avoid
it that's I would yield break up and
certainly something which I'd like to
stay away from possible the other thing
is have a look at something like this
I'm just going to tweak the question
ever so slightly a little bit yes the
track okay
have a look at this in this case you
don't have as many choices in this case
expanding you something you promise
getting almost what's different what
might change yeah okay so you you
entered the question underneath my
question let me rewind a little if the
thing that I've changed is just this
number yeah that's it right now what
that means is now the advise no longer
share anything in common right what are
the main reasons we expand like why do
we teach you this is because you can
click like terms where you have no other
option but you do have another option
because they are in college unlike that
question over there just delete them
leave them because then you can factor
over them
there's a college that don't leave it
there right it's what you're headed
towards sub factorize then if the
currently factorized form is good leave
it whereas if the curly-headed eyes hold
enjoy good like what am i going to pull
out that I suppose I can clog the X but
then this guy's still a problem right
then you have no choice but to
experience so what am I going to do over
here I'm going to get everything on one
side so if you're following along with
me you're working let's subtract now I
agree looks like a mess still work with
it what we call the fact I'm going to
pull out look carefully the N minus 2 is
an obvious click since their union
between the video there's other stuff in
there isn't it yeah I get inside pull
out some extra here any two extra here
so I'm going to go in there do that
sample big big brackets what I pulled 2x
explains to out of this where the liver
it's just through teaches three that's
all I got right
what about on here carefully so the twos
Golan one of the ends of X's is gone
which they do with an X and then I put
in X minus 2 so what lets you at this
point that was a lot of mental effort to
get there but this question now I think
we should gather science right let's
just finish this out so I live that
experts to their what they hear three
minus x squared plus 2x which watch out
for those science yeah you happy with
that I can't act like this fed up I'll
tie in fact maybe I'll make it a little
easier for you by pulling out a negative
this is going to be x squared minus two
X minus three
what would you do that X minus three X
plus one
I've had a bring full of this stuff back
are you have to in that so done one last
thing I'm going to do I pulled out a
negative waiting the ticket to come from
what I do that it was good I didn't will
not like to look at this so I didn't
like the back then I wanted to make this
morning basically and the coefficient
here and they give you one moment so I
pulled it out but I didn't like it there
somebody get rid of it
I'm going to multiply both sides by
negative one what happens to the right
hand side when I multiply by name is one
thing good the right hand side the right
hand side when I multiply the right-hand
side by negative one nothing happens to
that but because it was negative right
it's an inequality so what type of speed
for you directions changed okay
we're almost there now have a look at
this being what what is this thing even
okay well we recognize before we
recognize as a problem this is not a
quadratic it's a
it's a quartet the power is for not even
doing that name
what this basically means is now a
parabola it goes up and down like this
right or up and down like this if you
had a cubic cut the basic shape of a
cubic it just yeah it's going to go down
and then it's going to wave up again or
or in your reverse direction okay
so this is what happens in your power to
it turns around once so what happened to
you about three a 10-0 twice what do you
think happens when you have a power form
it turns around one more time like is
like that is the one two three points or
alternatively it does upside down just
like these guys - one two three equally
happy version sad version which do you
think this is now I would recruit into a
few versions how do I know that this is
sort of getting into something that
we're going to learn and a little more
rigor a little later on I want you to
think about what happens as X gets
bigger and bigger and bigger and bigger
right if X takes on a very large
positive value you're either going
really high or you go to really learn
really positive or really negative have
a look at this piece right as X gets
really large what happens to all of
these numbers like if extra say of
million right this is going to be
familiar right what is gonna be nine
hundred thousand I shouldn't have done
this me okay yeah it is I just we value
to that dance and I've enjoyed nine nine
shallot sorry this will be a million is
one - great
what's this side of all four bits of
this when external is the sign of all
for naught when it is positive right she
will fight for funding doubles together
what do you got again another positive
okay so this is the situation here
lastly what's going on to these numbers
here if I shoot half of the question
right like that you can enter that in a
flash right what would you here to be
about with this question
I want this thing to be less than zero
on do you agree so it either be between
negative 1 & 3
do you agree that's because this is the
shape of your head negative 1 & 3 do
agree that having pot there
y- wanted three reports that you read
off that why do you just magically turn
these backwards look at look at the
picture after what's significant are
negative 1 is 3 if that was all you had
one of the civilians are these points
then d intercept not then we think
that's where they intercept okay so have
a look at this guy's it's a happy what
we do before it's going to look like
that count how many times they intersect
1 twice three times four times what
would you guess the damage are look look
this one would give me 0 this will give
me 2 this one give me this won't give me
so I have written that not quite in the
right order
negative 1 0 2 3 don't worry about the
scale the question is not grasped the
question is solved okay okay look look
one last time I want to know exactly in
Lesson 0 where does that is less than 0
you tell me where is it less than 0
between here and here that purpose is 0
I want to write that down and between 2
3
son happy that make sense yeah